okay oh he's out he's out
[Music]
yeah okay i got him
just like a classic beck told
thanksgiving something's going to
explode from inside someone
oh yuck yucky
oh that is yep
he's alive they're already doing it
episode one that's i like this big deal
i like this i like john favreau was like
we are going
shooting this episode out of a cannon
there will not be a slow build to uh
yeah welcome back to new rockstars this
is our reaction to the mandalorian
season 2 premiere
the marshall here to be create dragons
well not anymore
thanks to mando timothy hilophant and
some iconic boba fett armor
stared down through a binary sunset bye
tamora morrison
the actor who played jango fett and
attack of the clones and a clone of boom
and therefore
would also look just like morrison is
boba fett
making this official boba fett lives
folks it's goofy death and return of the
jedi
not the last we're gonna see of him
think of the force
when he turned into kind of a human
bottle rocket and that flew into a
sarlacc
yeah who could forget yes
this is wikileaks it's our mandalorian
after show that explains to all the
droids out there why a green
little baby puppet makes them feel so
warm inside it might be hypertension
be careful get that looked at i'm eric
boss here with me
it's tommy bechtold hey buddy hey good
to be here wow you know there's nothing
like
new star wars content to make you feel
so much better in the world like this
was a little shot of sunshine
in my uh on my tv screen i was like i
mean i don't i don't know i just there's
something about the way this show is
done
uh that i i it's just such great
sci-fi like it's really fun i just i i
don't know we'll talk we'll get into it
more but man this was this was
some good medicine i needed so i hope
great uh
uh good sci-fi really great fantasy you
know the way that it it
fuses both the new with the old like
they're exploring
new horizons and this great western
simple
feel but then just sprinkles in little
things like the crate dragon from
from a new hope bringing back boba fett
and bringing back things from the chuck
windig books of a cop van
it's just like understands what star
wars fans really want from these stories
and just like has this
beautiful balance to have rose credit to
filoni's credit
and they have such an amazing team there
yeah well we'll be here every friday by
the way with these after shows tomorrow
will be my separate in-depth breakdown
of the episode the shot by
shot breakdown of all the hidden visual
details and this episode especially
was littered with subtle visual easter
eggs homages
audio sounds that like might sound
familiar and that's why it's so great
i'm gonna break it all down you're gonna
see that right away tomorrow so don't
worry
oh and uh by the way before tommy recaps
the episode for us i am currently
wearing this custom
this is the way shirt this is exclusive
from new rockstar's new official
merch store this mando shirt is our
limited run
latest obsession and uh oh hot damn we
just announced this on wednesday and
it's already almost sold out
wow i'm trying to get philip to order
more but we're not sure since it's
supposed to be a limited run
fingers crossed that he does we'll see
but the cool thing is that when you buy
it for just a few bucks more you can
also
write in a custom shout out it could be
a hot take a theory a question
uh screaming at your friends getting
revenge uh calling them out for whatever
thing they did wrong to you and not you
know paying their share of the rent on
time whatever it is
uh that's gonna appear beneath tommy and
me in these wikileaks episodes you can
actually see them below
uh our friend tyler hood said actually
jesus
is the way but whatever all right
okay okay and then uh
oh i see garrett says hey arnelle i know
you'll see this happy face it's your boy
yes
barnell and garrett we hope you see this
yeah uh
and thank you for supporting us thank
you to all the people down below who
support us uh
and uh hope you enjoy your merch uh when
you get it very soon
and you uh if you have not bought
merchant you can go to our great merch
store
uh check out all the amazing options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you know i've been browsing that merch
store eric my birthday is coming up i've
been dropping hints
all over with my family i say here's a
link
uh please search uh baby doll cut
t-shirts
size medium and uh one of each please
one of each and i told phillip i texted
philip yesterday that uh one way or
another i'm getting my manifesto
published on on this network
even if it's by two sentence shout outs
one at a time each week i will have my
my logic out there for the world to read
all right hey
the 2020 unibomber would have gotten his
message out that way i'm sure
the government is controlled by lizard
people ah it's your boy
all right tommy break down the episode
uh what happened this
week man what happened this week was
uh star wars magic at the gomorian
fighting arena mando meets gore koresh
voiced brilliantly by john leguizamo you
gotta love a new york city alien
i just i'm always a sucker for it after
a school
hey call a taxi cab we're gonna head
down to
gino's for a slice and maybe a bowl of
marinara
sauce first we're gonna take down some
banta steaks
uh anyway uh i i love it again it's the
magic of star wars where you're watching
this ridiculous accent on an alien
you're like this is good i care about
these characters
uh after scuffle where mando lets his
whistling birds sing
correct tells mando he can find another
mandalorian on tatooine
tatooine uh tattooing tatooine
getting uh the winner of multiple
pronunciation awards three different
characters said tattooing a different
way in this episode
which i love that is kind of realistic
it's the way like people
pronounce different cities uh all over
america different ways i'm looking at
you
warchester wooster worcester mando
and baby yoda return to the desert
planet and ride up to the sleepy town of
mos
pelgo where they meet the marshall cobb
vance played by timothy oliphant
wearing the famous armor of boba fett
pre-selling
thousands of action figures with that
red sweatshirt underneath the boba fett
armor
uh oh i just like as soon as he popped
up on screen a hundred dollars left my
bank account preemptively
they're like you will be pre-ordering
this uh which i gotta say with the armor
does not fit oliphant's body as well as
my hugs would
i would grab him wrap him safely and
feel his steel
against my steel and sound oh yeah
and you know uh i do agree it did fit
him awkwardly obviously it's by design
because it's not his armor
right but he kind of looked like a the
tall catcher on a litter league team
yeah just like
are you really 12 and he's like yes i'm
12. that's my wife and uh
the right child probably with the
bleachers but i'm still down junior
and he throws it too hard back to the
second base when he's like why do we
have to play with an adult on our team
yes he definitely he looked like a
sheriff woody doll dressed with boba
fett like uh
modifications but it was but i think
there's like a snake in my
uh starlight cave someone poor yeah
someone poisoned the sarlacc pit
uh but i think uh i think that it serves
the purpose of immediately letting us
know
this is not boba fett right like that
was the right the point was like it's
like this guy's wearing boba fett's
armor but it is not him
uh so cobb explains that he bought the
armor from jawas
after his town was overtaken by bandits
on the night the second death star
exploded which was a cool piece of like
again explaining the timeline and really
hammering it in for people that aren't
fanatical star wars fans like this is
something that if you've seen the movies
you can now grasp
really grasp when this is taking place i
love that they were watching on like
looped replay like they were in a sports
bar they're like yeah roll it again
huge missed cameo for al michaels to
play an alien
sportscaster do you believe in miracles
uh so so he used the armor and boba's
old weaponry
to liberate the town and protect its
people ever since
uh kind of eerily similar to deadwood
where one might say he came into a town
and uh basically kept it liberated for
for better or for worse uh
until that diabolical hearst came to
town but more on our deadwood after show
talking wood uh okay so the title
pending
yeah big wood talking talking wood
holden wood
uh laying wood we'll delete all this uh
okay
so no it's all staying in but a great
dragon terrorizes the town
and continues the star wars tradition of
ripping off dune a proud tradition
uh that uh it should be i believe
commended
mando agrees to help cobb slay the
dragon in exchange for boba's army
uh they team up with the tribe of tuscan
raiders proving
my theory that if two groups of people
that don't get along
uh can find common ground and a common
enemy in a
wild creature that's just trying to live
its life they can destroy anything
to me the tuscan raiders and and cobb
and his town uh uh maz pelgo there were
like two rival ant colonies that just
happened to establish near a house and
instead of
fighting each other for dominance and
survival they just decided to destroy
the house instead
it was very much it was very much like
i'm not taking the side of crate dragons
but it was like that great dragon was
just living its life it was just doing
what great dragons do and they were like
we got to kill this thing
hey it's a typical watchman ozymandias
argument right you want to bring
together the warring tribes and get some
ugly ass monster from somewhere else
for them to fight together that's right
uh so they they hatch a plan but their
plan to blow up its belly doesn't work
the dragon spews acid which was like was
like a great
like special power twist like it kind of
reminds me of like in a superhero movie
where like you discover a new power
it was like oh this thing spews acid uh
it's used acid now
it's use acid exactly
which uh clearly wasn't in the research
obviously they did not have the uh
the prep to know that that was coming
finally though
mando does kill the dragon by getting it
to eat a bantha lobantha sashimi
uh rob anthony with a ton of explosive
strap to it
boom goes the bantha duskin raiders and
townspeople rejoice finding common
ground
that was a wookie what is the thing they
make the same siren noise that was in
the rogue one trailer though
the sirens like the tuscan writers make
a very similar noise
uh yeah you know not what i was making
but you get what i'm saying it's there
we all hear it in our heads yeah mando
gets the armor back and in the binary
sunset of darwin tomorrow morrison the
true boba fett
watches them from a cliff wow i
yes that to me i i'm not gonna lie
when i saw timothy oliphant's character
show up before it was revealed i mean
the voice immediately gave it away but
when i saw that character show up there
was a little party that was like
oh is this gonna be the boba fett thing
it's just like his armor is on a
different person
and i mean i guess it's still cool to
see the armor on screen again but
there was a little disappointment in me
but then the more as the episode went on
i'm like
the true star wars storytelling
tradition is boba fett is out there
somewhere he's got to be
like i mean he's always there he's
always watching so uh what'd you think
overall of the episode uh i loved it and
i think that
um having him watch the binary sunset
was an interesting
choice right because uh the binary
sunset symbolizes hope and
in a weird way boba fett still being
alive has been like a source of hope for
many star wars die hards to be like
yes some choices were made in a lot of
these movies but i still cling to hope
that my version of these movies could
still exist right and like lo and behold
uh what was once a joke in patton
oswalt's uh parks and rec scene
yeah is now officially canon i mean
depending who you ask
boba fett had survived and it that's
always been true
right and now we get to see it finally
on screen in a major star wars title
played by tamora morrison the fact that
they were able to get him back i think
is so cool
now some people say it might be rex the
clone because yes all clones do look
exactly like
tomorrow morrison right in this uh in
this universe but
obviously it's boba fett there's there's
no doubt in my mind that that's who this
is absolutely
and and awesome what an awesome awesome
awesome moment and and what an awesome
episode to like uh
just be a simple tale of two tribes
coming together to
to slay the dragon and it felt so
medieval in a way there's a fusion of a
western uh imagery obviously it felt
like a spaghetti western in the town
of mosfelgo but once they they worked
together it felt like we were watching
you know two arthurian clans coming
together to
literally slay the dragon uh and that's
what like saves the kingdom and it was
just a
simple simple storytelling that i think
we appreciate it but um
there was a thematic through line that i
really appreciated just to get nerdy
about the deeper meaning that i
uh interpreted here um this idea of
armor
so like amanda's original mission which
i think it's easy to forget
this episode began with him like trying
to track down
another mandalorian to help him network
via the mandalorian coverts he called it
which i just think are the the sewer
clubhouse
connection yep whatever that is um and
he wanted to
use that i guess to find baby yoda's
kind
and he kept he repeated this he's like
i've been requested i've been quested
to bring this one back to its kind he
kind of like robotically
echoes it as if the child's name is john
connor
it's like it's so weird that he has that
one line but uh
all of that changes on a dime the second
that mando realizes that cobb vanth is
not a mandalorian
it's like his whole world stops and then
he's like screw the mission
baby yoda's kind can wait until next
episode commando
this is stolen valor it is an insult
right it must be addressed uh
and in a way he's obsessed with it to us
the armor is the thing it's not the
thing inside the armor it's the shell
mando's shell is more important
to his own identity and his safety than
uh
who he is as a human being even gore
quresh
talks about mando like he's an animal
wanted only for his pelt
normally i have to seek out remnants of
you mandalorians
in your hidden hives to harvest your
precious
shiny shells think about there is some
parallelism between mando's shell game
and the layers of armor to the beast
cobb says that he has never heard of an
abandoned sarlacc pit to which amanda
responds well unless the dragon ate the
sarlacc
right and then we know the sarlacc ate
boba fett so we kind of got this like
turducken here you know yes a russian
nesting doll
whatever you want to call it um and the
crate dragon's flesh is impenetrable he
kind of has his armor too only by
blowing it up from the inside can it be
killed
and then in its flesh there's this weird
moment that tuscan raiders find this
pearl
what the hell is that it's some weird
true prize some mystery egg you might
call it it's kind of
the suga of this season um but
mando doesn't care at all about whatever
that is he
walks away he has his armor that is his
prize and
it's interesting to note that that armor
has layers to its story before cobb the
armor belonged to boba fett and before
boba fett jango fett
and according to lord jango fett was
from the planet concord dawn it was a
mandalorian world but the government of
mandalore disavowed him
uh they claimed that he stole
mandalorian armor so
it's kind of a mixed story he claims to
be mandalorian it's probably
part of his appropriation boba fett
certainly isn't mandalorian he was born
on camino um
so we should also point out that that
armor is not
bescar canonically it's supposed to be a
durasteel alloy
which is makes it interesting why mando
insisted on taking it back because it's
while it is mandalorian design it is not
made of bescar
um but i think we're talking about this
repurposing you know taking things that
don't belong to you and finding a new
way to use them that
is the story of star wars one generation
stealing the discarded junk from the
past generation
and wearing it like armor just because
they need something to protect
themselves from the hostile world
maf gideon does this with the dark saber
rey did it with her pod racer engine
speeder on jakku which
if you watch cobb does the same thing he
has a pod racer engine that he uses a
speeder bike
um really star wars i think is a story
of hermit crabs they're just swapping
shells and they never know or care about
the true history of the armor that they
are now clinging to that's kind of what
makes it great it's a kind of a
one-man's trash story yeah i
i completely agree and uh and also uh
that expands all the way out to i
believe the creatives behind star wars
you know new generations of writers
are forced to mine star discarded star
wars
characters and worlds to create new
content
so it's like you know i mean it's it's
an all-encompassing philosophy
uh yeah very very interesting and we do
have some questions we're going to dig
into before
we do that though we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
support for wookiee leaks is brought to
you by
manscaped the best admins below the way
screw mean
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels they obsess
over their technology
to provide you the best tools for your
grooming experience
tommy and i both love man's skin i took
a manscape to my face yesterday
and let me tell you uh no cuts
no cuts you will not see any more pubes
on tommy's face thanks demands
not not not today anyway but i got a
busy saturday planned so
uh look we all want to look good and
feel good naked that's why manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer the
manscaped engineering team spent 18
months perfecting the greatest
ball hair trimmer ever created and just
released their new
and improved lawnmower 3.0 it's their
third generation trimmer it features a
cutting edge ceramic blade with advanced
skin
technology to reduce grooming accidents
uh it's waterproof it has a battery that
will last up to
90 minutes that's long enough to hack
all the way through a wookie's
underground
yeah yikes 90 minutes yeah most of the
time you're you're
wrestling and fighting the wookie off
that's right
if you can survive it you'll get a nice
clean patch of skin beautiful and if
you've ever
pet a shorn wookie let me tell you they
are
oh it's just there's something about a
freshly shaved wookie that makes you
want to you throw it all away and move
to
the wookie planet the lawn mower also
has a 7000 rpm motor which isn't quite
enough to do the kessel run in less than
12 parsecs but it will do the testicle
run
in zero bag snips yeah
that's a that's the off-screen producer
zach
that had his that had his fingerprints
all over it
and then he also heard i'm not sorry for
that joke and you shouldn't be sorry
about your desire to have a nice and
tidy downstairs
that's right zach you shouldn't no
apologies
good job zach all right folks get 20
off and free shipping on this manscaped
a deal with the code
mandalorian at manscape.com that is 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use the code
mandalorian your balls oh thank you
all right let's move on to some of the
big questions we have from this episode
the obvious one being
boba fett is back how did he survive the
sarlacc
and are we gonna see him face mando to
get his armor back at some point this
season
you know i i think uh to answer the
first question
i mean the logical thing is that he
somehow regurgitated you know like he
he i mean he's a resourceful uh
resourceful man
as we know to be a bounty hunter you
have to be able to evade and escape and
get out of uh
scrapes and sticky situations and uh i
i have to think that he triggered some
sort of regurgitation from the sarlacc
and uh spewed his way back out into the
grainy sands the coarse and irritable
sands of tattooing
yeah and i think this episode might have
given us a clue as to
um the story of the crate dragon eating
the sarlacc eating you know that kind of
uh
food chain because for one it gives us a
sense of a vulnerability the starlight
when a star like eats you you're
supposed to be
uh digested slowly slowly slowly
uh and i wonder if the crate dragon
eating it that acidic
uh whatever the spewing juices of the
crate dragon was able to dissolve the
sarlacc
would not dissolve the armor and that's
why like you could see
mando his his armor didn't maybe the
boba fett armor didn't dissolve
although when you when you saw cobb and
wearing it it did look a little corroded
yeah
it had some of the same nicks and
scratches that we saw before which were
something
boba looked a little worse for wear yeah
he did he did he had some scarring on
him which i think that's
why some people thought it might have
been rex from the series because he has
some scarring but uh yeah uh for sure
for sure
but this question of will beaufett try
to get his armor back from mando
i i have to see i'm
torn on this a little bit because
like you said boba fett is not a
mandalorian so he doesn't
have the mandel like the religious
connection to the the helmet and the and
the armor
you know as uh as mando says in the
first season
weapons are part of my religion and and
you know and presumably the armor is a
part of that
i don't know that boba fett i mean
obviously he seems prideful
right like i mean the little the little
glimpses we have of him in
in other materials like he seems like a
person who has like an ego
and surprised so like the idea of
something stolen from him
and taken from him against his will i
think is what would motivate him to get
it back but i wonder if
this is going to be if there's a
possibility where this is a redemption
tale
where like we have an aging older boba
fett who's been humbled
through these circumstances he's been
injured he's been you know and i wonder
if this is a chance for him
now that the helmet is off we get to
really meet the character right
so i wonder if this is going to be a
chance where instead he is
an unlikely ally and and maybe and maybe
earns the armor back
rather than getting it through conflict
you know what's interesting is like
so boba fett clearly survived the
sarlacc and maybe the crate dragon ii
um so if he survived why would he part
ways was it a matter if he just like
was tired and he you know dragged
himself out into the sand and then jawas
found him and then took it off him
right maybe but i doubt it i think boba
fett might have intentionally parted
ways with the armor
sure uh sold it to jawas and that's how
it ended up in their hands because
i don't know if he was that i agree with
you i don't know if he's gonna be that
eager to chase down amanda to get that
armor back he might have moved on
but i think what might happen which this
kind of brings us into our next question
about uh the nature of boba fett's armor
um we know from like you know past
canon that technically boba fett's armor
is supposed to be made of dura steel
not baskar uh it's a different alloy of
metal
i got fact checked on that in the
comments of a video a couple of weeks
ago
got him guys good we got him good good
work um
but like i think that's very interesting
because maybe that could be a way
that um mando is actually willing to
part with it and get it back in boba
fett's hands because
maybe he brings it back to his armor and
they're like this isn't vescar
but it looks like mandalorian armor and
maybe that's what brings them back to
boba fett is they're like whoever you
got this from is this uh bounty hunter
who did cross paths with the jedi
maybe you should go talk to him so then
maybe it's it's a not an antagonistic
relationship between these two yeah
we'll see
uh i think that's great yeah this uh
whole episode did some cool stuff with
humanizing the tuscan raiders in ways
that we haven't seen since uh attack of
the clones yeah um i i loved seeing them
as a strategic
as uh capable of making mistakes as uh
mixed morality
um what did you make of it tommy uh um
you know i thought that the again the
the the idea of them interacting in a
non-hostile way with other species
and other you know other other tribes on
tatooine was what was interesting to me
like
and i think you you said it good in the
summary like the or rather in the in the
deeper meaning section
the the idea of this just being a
classic uh
village being tormented by dragon
literally a crate dragon in this case
uh and villagers having to rise up to
defeat the dragon with a
mysterious knight from far away coming
in to help them slay
the dragon i just like yeah i like the
uh similar to you i like the way that
they were that they were humanized and
given
a spectrum of emotions rather than just
like hostile hollering
wild savages for lack of a better word
you know like that are
often often others or outside forces are
portrayed that way in film no matter
what the
circumstances are i like that you know
both sides were fallible both sides were
emotional and reactionary and ultimately
both sides were rational like you said
you could could realize like if we don't
come together
this thing is just going to keep eating
people and ultimately at a certain point
we're all going to get eaten by it so
like or have to leave our homes so
right uh a simple good message that has
been true since the dawn of time
um but uh i'm curious do you think we're
done with tattooing for now this season
or do you think it could be possible
that maybe next episode could open
with the mandalorian still on tatooine
and some last minute complications when
he tries to leave
well so i i don't think we're done short
answer i don't think we're done with
tatooine
i think one thing that we do know from
the first season of mandalorian is that
this show is very patient
they are willing to leave something for
multiple episodes
only to come back to it so there's a
chance that we will go we will be
diverted to a different point of the
story for the next three four episodes
but i think too much was left unanswered
on tattooing for us to be done with it
right like you can't end the episode
with boba fett staring at at uh at twin
suns and being like
okay well that's the last of that that's
closure on that it's like obviously
yeah and i don't think he's going he's i
think much like obi-wan kenobi he's
gonna have to be coerced off that planet
you know what i mean it feels like he's
been there for a while so
yeah yeah yeah i i think we also have
the unanswered question of fenix shand
and who that was was that cobb vanth who
picked her up at the end of episode five
i was thinking they would
would have revealed that or was that
actually boba fett who picked her up
um we'll see obviously we're gonna go
back there i
have a feeling that for now we're done i
don't think they're gonna
follow i think that seemed to be a tease
for the whole season yeah of uh boba
fett
and i think they're gonna find their way
back to it but i think he's gonna move
on to the next step of his process to
return the child
or maybe he's gonna try to sync back up
with the armorer and he'll find
something out about the
the dirt steel armor we'll see all right
uh we're now going to
wrap things up with our favorite segment
the baby yoda give
rap the uh most giftable baby yoda
moments to bring us cheers i guess we're
now heading into the holiday season
yes uh there were this wasn't a huge
baby yoda episode he was more just kind
of watching from the sidelines but there
were
some moments um let's start with our
number three baby ota squinting because
the fire is too bright for his baby eyes
oh
this is this is a good gift if you uh
feel like oh i
i'm i'm hungover what day is it
you know that's kind of a good squint a
squinter i went too hard
last night i trick-or-treated too
crazily uh
all right number two uh of course we
talked about this in our uh last week
episode baby yoda nopes out of the fight
by hiding this carrier and that's
so great so great that's never not gonna
get a laugh from me yeah
and you know what it is uh there's a lot
of like old western vibes in this
episode that was like our first tease of
that it felt like the old
uh saloon barton to be like uh oh we got
trouble in town
also also some great great like
western catchphrases from timothy
oliphant like fitted into the world of
star wars like where he's like yeah
sometimes
both suns shine on you or something like
that yeah it was like both sides
it was it was like it was like something
like similar to like to like you know
every once in a while the sun shines on
your ass or something there's some
western quote that's like that
but it was that but it mentioned the two
sons yeah
and i also yeah i liked how he brought
back one breast he's like he's picking
us off like womp rats and he's like do
you have any other metaphor to use sir
he's just done and didn't amy sedaris
character also talk about wombrats
whop rats are a very big deal yeah huge
um but our number one baby oda get from
this episode of course baby yoda hiding
in the spittoon
oh yes that was a good one actually junk
38 on twitter caption that says
is the election over again i feel the
same
i i also would like to hide in a
spittoon uh until the election is over
yep well uh be sure to send us your
favorite baby ota gifts each week use
the hashtag wikileaks it's two e's
in uh at the end of wookie uh and we
will try to feature it in the episode oh
also speaking of other shout outs we
want to
hopefully you've been seeing all these
great comments from the people who
bought the this is away shirt
uh uh early monika captioned
vote november 3rd and asks what is the
first thing everyone will do
post pandemic keep it pg absolutely
thank you monica
uh everyone vote november 3rd try to
vote early if you can
do it safely mask up however you feel
most comfortable
uh post pandemic hmm what do you think
tommy
i'm not going to watch that songbird
movie that's for sure no
i i i auditioned for that and i've never
been happier to not be in something
because i think that movie is going to
be
maligned when it comes out i'm going to
be spending a lot of time with my son
uh i will be spending a lot of time with
my son but what's better than one son
oh that's right twins and twins
they're definitely fraternal uh but i
love them both equally
no matter what so uh one's looking a bit
uh sloth
baby am i you bad you've been
bad you've been you guys hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh i think monica the thing i'll do
after the pandemic's over is
go to all my friends weddings that they
all had to
yeah holy cow they're gonna be crazy i
think we'll be at some of the same ones
and yeah boy is there gonna be a lot of
them maybe we'll get married eric and i
might have a civil ceremony we might
make it maybe
hey anything's possible right yeah um
hey and uh it's all of you watching one
last reminder that you can get this
exclusive new rockstars this is away
shirt at our new rockstars merch store
along with a ton of other great options
including there's like a hi i'm eric
cloth shirt
that you might you can get all this at
newrockstarsmerch.com
but that's it for this episode of wookie
leaks thank you tommy it's been so great
and i'm so excited watching this season
with you me too a lot of fun
stuff absolutely thank you eric your
insight as always is
uh is is a lot of fun to listen to uh
you can follow me at eavos follow
tommy at tommybechtold and subscribe to
new rockstars on youtube
but also subscribe to the wikileaks
podcast feed wherever you get your
podcasts
and you can leave us a nice rating
review if you don't mind that would
really help people get their eyes
and ears on this i'll see you tomorrow
for the easter egg breakdown on the
channel but
we will see all of us uh next friday for
our next after show
of episode two technically uh chapter 10
uh but until then
we have spoken
[Music]
you